so
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
meine comic-torte dieses Jahr kam mir
bei euch richtig gut an und deswegen
habe ich mir gedacht machen wir doch
einen Christmas Comic cake dieses Mal
aber keine ganze Torte sondern ein
Kuchenstück und damit das Kuchenstück
von der Zubereitungszeit her einfach
nicht so aufwendig wird backen wir jetzt
zuerst einmal eine rechteckige
Tortenplatte bestehend aus einem
mandelrührteig und damit geht es direkt
los für den Teig verwende ich zwei Eier
eine Prise Salz 100g Zucker etwas Tonka
Paste jeweils 100 g Buttermilch und
Sonnenblumenöl 160 g Mehl plus einen
Teelöffel Backpulver oder nimmt einfach
das backmehl da ist schon mit dabei 70g
gemahlene Mandeln und rote Lebensmittel
verpaste ich habe den Ofen schon
vorgeheizt hier habe ich auch meine
Backform das ist quasi mein rechteckiger
Backrahmen auf 20 x 30 cm eingestellt
das ist später dann die Backplatte
und dann kann ich jetzt zuerst einmal
die Eier mit dem Zucker Salz und der
Tonka Paste für etwa 4 bis 5 Minuten
cremig verrühren anschließend kann man
dann die zwei Flüssigkeiten mit dazu und
hier gebt ihr gerne auch schon die rote
lebensmittelfarpaste mit ein damit sie
sich eben schon mal schön vermengt zum
Schluss kommen jetzt noch die trockenen
Zutaten rein die wirklich nur ganz kurz
unterrühren bis sich das Mehl vermengt
hat dann füllt ihr den ganzen Teig in
die Backform ein streicht alles glatt
und dann kommt schon ab in den Backofen
und die Zwischenzeit können wir dann
direkt nutzen um die Creme herzustellen
[Musik]
für die Creme verwende ich 150 Gramm
weiche Butter 150 Gramm Puderzucker 150
Frischkäse und etwas Vanilleextrakt das
sind überschaubare Zutaten indem wir
zuerst die weiche Butter und verrührt
sie mit dem Frischkäse nein und hat die
nicht
die weiche Butter und verrätst du mit
dem Puderzucker schön cremig damit sie
richtig schön weiß cremig ist es dauert
vier bis fünf Minuten
[Musik]
ich wollte ein puderzucker sieben ich
habe extra mitziehen
[Musik]
schön luftig und fluffig sieht die Masse
jetzt aus da kommt der Frischkäse dazu
Vanilleextrakt und dann ist die Creme
fertig
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier den fertigen Kuchen
der wird jetzt einmal
so ein bisschen weil die Decke muss ich
sagen ist ein bisschen uneben das
schneide ich einmal kurz perfekt gerade
normalerweise stört sie nicht sind jetzt
echt Kleinigkeiten aber ich will den
Comic cake perfekt haben
[Musik]
Entschuldigung
meine kaputte ja sie nimmt
oh danke danke schön Gott hier ist
wieder eine Sauerei
mach mal kurz sauber
tschüss und jetzt habe ich hier eine
Schablone die kann ich jetzt hier drauf
setzen und dann quasi 4 Dreiecke
zuschneiden
[Musik]
dann habe ich jetzt hier den ersten
Boden
jetzt kommt jetzt hier drauf die Creme
habe ich einfach in den Spritzbeutel
gefüllt mit großer Lochtülle damit kann
ich sie nämlich perfekt überall schön
verteilen
[Musik]
die Torte ist gefüllt und kommt
abgedeckt in den Kühlschrank die
Tortencreme lasse ich hier kurz stehen
es dauert jetzt so ungefähr 15 20
Minuten bis die Buttercreme fest wird
ihr könnt auch ganz ganz einfach
schneller
da gibt's gleich weiter mit dem schönen
saftigen Kuchen
[Musik]
dann kommt jetzt eine schöne dünne
Schicht Creme hier außen auf die Torte
damit sie einfach perfekt gerade wird
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hier noch und dann
Stift süß
so ganz ungewohnt so ein einziges
Tortenstück ein streichen
okay da kommst du jetzt noch mal in den
Kühlschrank für ungefähr eine Stunde
damit du schön fest wirst und ich dich
hübsch dekorieren kann
es hätte doch 100 Gramm Butter 100 Gramm
Buttercreme gereicht aber ich habe
lieber ein bisschen mehr zu viel als zu
wenig
wow das ist mal ein tolles Stücker
jetzt wird die Torte mit Fondant
eingekleidet und da könnt ihr jetzt
quasi die Optik der Torte bestimmen das
Schokotorte sein Erdbeertorte
Weihnachtstorte ganz wie ihr möchtet und
ich Texte jetzt nicht einmal so komplett
ein sondern Teil für Teil das heißt
erstmal hier vorne den Bereich bei mir
wird eine Schokoladentorte deswegen
etwas braunen Fondant nehmen und einfach
auf Becker Stärke schön ausrollen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
tatsächlich könnt ihr für solche Parts
wenn Sie wenn es nicht wirklich eine
Fondant Decke ist sondern wirklich nur
so ein Fondant Strang könnt ihr auch
immer die nudelwalze nehmen von der
Kenwood oder von der KitchenAid denn
damit lässt sich das immer schön
gleichmäßig ausräumen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
9 cm breit
[Musik]
ich muss das jetzt kurz ausmessen
wie lange die Seite ist
mache ich einfach mit der Backmatte 18
und 18 gibt 36
Glück gehabt Frau Sally
[Musik]
und jetzt einfach hier vorne quasi
entlang setzen
[Musik]
und dann nehmt ihr euch am besten so
zwei teigkarten und könnt hier wirklich
immer schön das andrücken da wird auch
schön gerade
schon mal hier die zwei Seiten oben
drüber kommt jetzt eine Decke und zwar
ein weißer Zuckerguss das ist auch
weißer Fondant und dafür jetzt auch
schön ausrollen
[Musik]
und ich nehme jetzt hier die Schablone
mit der ich quasi die Torte geschnitten
habe und schneit es jetzt so dass hier
kleine Wellenlinien sind das ist nämlich
dann der Zuckerguss
[Musik]
dann hier hinten zu machen einfach einen
Rechteck
9 cm hoch 11 cm breit
[Musik]
so und hier mache ich jetzt noch so ein
paar hellen rein
als wäre es mit der Teigkarte
durchgezogen
[Musik]
also tut euch da ein bisschen leichter
wenn ihr Ganache nehmt aber ich wollte
halt dass es eine Torte ist die so
fluffig locker und leicht ist und eben
nicht so fest miteinander aber eine
Ganache ist zum Dekorieren schon
einfacher weil dann zum Beispiel wie
hier die Tortencreme nicht rausgucken
würde
jetzt hier auch nicht schlimm weil
später diese Linien außen rumkommen okay
dann kommt jetzt die weiße tortendecke
drauf
wartete
und hier mache ich nur so dass es sich
locker nach unten bewegt
[Musik]
und dann ganz locker nach unten
hier so ein bisschen ankleben mit Wasser
oder Essbarem Kleber
im Grunde ist die Torte erstmal fertig
also das Grundgerüst steht ich will aber
dass sie noch also wie ein
angeschnittenes Stück Kuchen aussieht
oder Torte deswegen kommen noch eine
Cremeschicht rein und im Prinzip müsst
euch immer überlegen wie würde die Torte
aussehen wenn ich sie zeichne ich habe
mir natürlich auch eine Zeichnung
gemacht natürlich so sieht sie aus und
so ähnlich möchte ich sie auch gestalten
und man muss sich immer so ein bisschen
in diese Comic Torte halt reindenken das
heißt die Linien die ich auch jetzt
mache für die Creme nicht zu perfekt
machen also schon so ein bisschen dicker
und dünner denn es soll gezeichnet
aussehen
[Musik]
dann machen wir hier auch einen roten
Strang für eine Fruchtfüllung
[Musik]
die Kerze gold
oder rot
dicke rote Kerze
tannenzweigend und ein Hauch von
Vanilleextrakt legt jetzt in der Luft
macht euch jetzt bereit bald ist es so
weit denn Weihnachten bis Weihnachten
ist nicht mehr weit bis Weihnachten bis
Weihnachten ist nicht mehr weit
dicke rote Kerze
tannenzweigend und ein Hauch von
Zärtlichkeit liegt jetzt in der Luft
macht euch jetzt bereit bald ist es
soweit bis Weihnachten bis Weihnachten
ist nicht mehr weit bis Weihnachten bis
Weihnachten ist nicht mehr weit
[Applaus]
hier habe ich jetzt eine Kerze also das
ist praktisch Fondant mit etwas CMC
Pulver damit die Kerze vorne auch in der
Torte steht ich muss das jetzt echt mal
ausmessen also der Stab und dann ist
noch Platz für das
also hier quasi die Kerze rein und das
Gute ist dass bei diesen Torten wo quasi
was mit
cartoon gemacht wird also im comic style
das muss nicht so perfekt sein also die
Kerze muss jetzt nicht perfekt gerade
sein sondern die darf und soll auch so
ein bisschen gewellt sein das ist ja der
Effekt den wir später dabei
vielleicht schaffe ich sogar so ein
Tropfen irgendwie
und dann
hier
ja
das sieht jetzt noch komisch aus aber es
wird gleich schön jetzt brauche ich
etwas rot und gelb
wird nämlich das Feuer
und hier immer alles was Aushärten soll
immer mit CMC Pulver
und wenn ihr die Flamme einfach so ein
bisschen marmoriert lasst dann sieht es
auch schön aus
[Musik]
dann forme ich daraus einen Sahnetupfer
am besten eine lange Rolle die nach oben
hin etwas spitzer zugeht und dann in
sich drehen
deswegen mache ich das jetzt nicht das
Schokolade
denn aus Schokolade sieht das immer
etwas seltsam aus
[Musik]
für das wir Sahne oder wir mit einer
großen Lochtülle später mit der
Umrandung wird das alles das wird gut
okay dann habe ich hier noch ein paar
Bäumchen und zwar habe ich jetzt hier
eine Pralinen Silikonform da könnt ihr
Schokolade reinmachen oder geschmolzenen
Zucker und habe dann quasi so kleine
Kegel und wenn ich hier von dann weich
knetet mit CMC Pulver und hier rein geht
dann habt ihr kleine Tannenbäumchen
ja die sind süß
die kommen da hin
ich glaube so
zwei
ja das sieht schön aus
[Musik]
und dann
noch eine kleine Zuckerstange
da brauche ich jetzt etwas weiß und rot
vom beides zu einem gleichmäßigen Strang
und der wird dann in sich gezwirbelt und
dann noch einmal gedreht
[Musik]
und dann gibt es jetzt noch einen gelben
Stern und sobald ich den mit CMC gemacht
und ausgerollt und ausgestochen habe
kommt die Torte erstmal in den
Kühlschrank damit alles etwas aushärten
kann dann sind es nur noch kleine
Feinheiten
[Musik]
neuer Tag neues Glück so sieht die Comic
Torte jetzt aus ich habe jetzt über
Nacht den Kühlschrank gestellt nicht
abgedeckt damit der Fondant nicht feucht
wird und jetzt ist auch alles schön fest
geworden die Torte ist gut durchgekühlt
und damit sie jetzt aussieht wie eine
Comic Torte fehlen jetzt natürlich die
schwarze Umrandungen dafür nehme ich
schwarzen Fondant ihr könnt aber auch
Marzipan nehmen und alles was ihr tun
müsst ist quasi euch diese Linien zu
machen und dann an die kompletten Ränder
zu kleben also wenn man von vorne schaut
und sich überlegt wie sieht eine gemalte
gezeichnete Torte aus sind es quasi alle
Linien die ihr hier seht hier natürlich
auch dazwischen die Linien müssen auch
nicht immer durchgehen sein die dürfen
noch mal unterbrochen werden und dann
seht ihr vielleicht oh hier oder da
können wir noch so ein Klecks auf die
Marmelade auf diesen Fruchtaufstrich
machen oder da oben bei der Kerze noch
wie so eine Art runtertropfende
Wachsreste machen und das versuche ich
jetzt eben mit dem schwarzen Fondant
ankleben könnte das einfach mit Wasser
oder mit essbarem
und dann würde ich sagen geht jetzt los
dann nehmt ihr euch ein bisschen Zeit
dafür
[Musik]
also ihr müsst euch eine Vorderseite
aussuchen und dann immer dort die
Umrandungen machen
[Musik]
bei der letzten Torte dachte ich ja echt
cool aus weil irgendwann verliert man so
den Blick zu dem was man vor sich hat
und dann im Video oder auf den Fotos
dachte ich mir auch richtig gut
einfach gut
doch ein cooler Effekt
[Musik]
also für alles was so sehr viel
Feingefühl und Feinmotorik erfordert
könnt ihr euch echt einen trockenen
Pinsel nehmen und dann diese Linien so
ein bisschen andrücken weil mit den
Fingern kommt man da echt nicht überall
dran weil das teilweise sehr sehr kleine
Sachen sind
diese Zuckerstange zum Beispiel
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nasser Pinsel zum kleben und trockener
Pinsel zum aufdrücken
ja
[Musik]
okay der Stern
nee der Stern ist
so da oben noch die Zuckerstange
[Musik]
dann schaue ich mal was noch fehlt
ich glaube die mache ich so
und
okay
also an für sich ist die Torte erstmal
fertig sie ist mir tatsächlich noch ein
bisschen zu nackt deswegen werde ich
noch ein paar Streu Kugeln also so
streutech platzieren ein bisschen hier
so eine teigstruktur mit schwarzen
Linien machen und dann schaue ich mal
was noch so kommt
ganz cool
ich habe jetzt noch die kleinen Kugeln
gemacht und weil der normale
zuckerstreute einfach nicht passt dann
muss natürlich auch im Comic-Stil sein
die kann man dann hier auch draufsetzen
und dann sieht es schon ziemlich cool
aus auch hier auf die Platte
[Musik]
die Torte war das eine aber die
Tortenplatte die ist richtig knifflig
toll aber ich kriege es hin ich kriege
es hin ich will es jetzt perfekt haben
[Musik]
da feedbackt man doch schon beim
Zugucken mit oder so hält die Schlange
jetzt
oder nicht
hältst du jetzt oder bleibt sie jetzt ab
oder bringst du die alte unterfordert
nein
was ist schon Ninja Warriors wenn man
Sally beim Backen zu gucken kann wie sie
mit der fondantschlange kämpft
habe es geschafft bin weiter
[Musik]
ich bin fertig die Comic Christmas Torte
ist fertig
die fotografieren wir jetzt und dann
wird angeschnitten
die sieht echt cool aus
gut geworden gefällt mir sehr gut
[Musik]
du darfst kommen zum Probieren
so sieht richtig cool aus
vorbei laufen habe gedacht wow echt cool
und ich weiß es gerade voll viele
Zuschauer Fans von diesen Torten sind
einfach cool aus Baiser gemacht
okay dann schneide ich jetzt ein
Tortenstück aus dem Tortenstück für mein
Tortenstück
ich schneide jetzt den Tortenstück aus
dem Tortenstück für mein Tortenstück
die Grundschullehrerin nicht schön
weg weil ich will die nicht
durchschneiden die Kugel ist doch M&Ms
nehmen können nein das passt nicht zum
Stil ich habe die extra so gemacht damit
auch Mathe ah okay tut mir leid machen
können
das ist der Eyecatcher auf jeder Party
auf jeden kuchendingt
ist das Ding jetzt echt oder ist es
nicht echt ja und dann eigentlich erst
beim Anschnitt kommt so durch aha okay
it's not a comic
[Musik]
okay
so
jetzt haben wir zivilisierte Menschen
oh cool
[Musik]
ich liebe so Torten wirklich aber
ich mag kein Fondant Essen nein
das ist einfach nur zuckersüß und ist
zwar schade wenn man ihn nicht mit ist
aber es ist halt irgendwo einfach nur
Zucker
richtig gut
also
probiert gerne mal aus ich finde was an
der Torte ganz cool ist dass man kreativ
sein kann man kann ja wirklich und
Tortenstück kreieren also könnte sowas
auch zum Valentinstag machen zum
Geburtstag machen das ist eine
weihnachtstor aber ihr könnt da wirklich
komplett kreativ sein und jede Thematik
auch mit reinbringen also man kann ja
auch eine coole Motivtorte draus machen
und quasi keine Ahnung Minions egal was
auch immer
und man kann Dinge auch verändern wie
gesagt da oben hätte ich gesehen
genommen
diesjährige Weihnachtstorte nächste
Woche gibt's aber auch noch eine
Lebkuchenmann so eine 3d-torte also
können da wirklich entscheiden was ist
bei euch zu Weihnachten gibt oder ob ihr
sagt ich mache ganz klassisch Sallys
schneetorte und ganz ganz wichtig eine
besinnliche Weihnachtszeit wünschen wir
euch ja im Kreise eurer Familie ja passt
auf Euch auf bleibt gesund
gesundheitlich
oh mein Gott
wir haben zwei Kinder wir jeder weiß was
er tun
[Musik]